[Applaudissements]
alors c'est très simple orateurs gilles
isabelle contre gad et kiev donc c'est
très simple si la finale ils vont jouer
d'abord vous allez voir comment ça se
passe en fait je vais poser des
questions isabelle vous vous devez
répondre que par oui ou non c'est à dire
à ce que par un os qu il connaît votre
âge
si vous dites oui il doit dire votre âge
derrière oui mais je le frappe s'il le
nie un boum c'est toujours la balle 1 45
secondes de question et après on aura
gardé quelques attentions
nope isabelle gilles connaît-il la
partie de votre physique que l'on
complimente le plus oui le ffs les stops
non stop
c'était quoi il y eu les yeux pâles ffs
temps qu'il est con merci attention on
repart de votre position sexuelle
préférées oui la danse de la chatte êtes
nous dégoter la levrette la femelle du
chopin
moi je te jure les forums étaient mal
mais moi aussi
aussi hier mon neveu qui m'a dit qu'il
regardait l'émission avec ses potes là
vraiment aussi c'était jeunes ils sont
assez grasse race et leur assure des
jeunes là non non mais oui bah ils sont
obligés de les voir aller attention
c'est reparti votre plus grande qualité
ce qui la connaît oui oui il est
beaucoup plus intelligent qu'elle n'en a
l'air
non c'est pas ça c'est la générosité
merci la date de votre dernier rapport
sexuel
oui 1789
[Rires]
on avait un doute mais tu vas faire la
première page 10 ghz rep mc qui commence
à te la raconter c'était belgrade
attention du parti l'animateur télé que
vous ne supportez pas où l'animatrice ce
qui la connaît oui mais où c'est moi qui
l'a connu louis roques et laurent
ruquier on sait qui mais justement je ne
sais pas où vous mamie léa salamé
ah oui si c'est vrai ya salama hic oui
c'est une journaliste va bien amy est
très sympa pourtant j'adore silo oui
effectivement animateurs journalistes
raccord vert c'est la mémoire on en est
où
alors c'est nous c'est normal croiser
debout comme ça je suis pour savoir
d'injuste c'est dans le jeu parce que
vous avez joué à presser dans le jeu est
assurée de la peinture à position est
bonne on attend sa part la taille de
votre tour de poitrine est ce qui la
connaît oui oui
15a
commérages de temps perdu
allez attention aussi reparti votre look
bah oui c'est moi 76 c'est vachement
bien
76 de ton poitrine puis quand les
omoplates avec voilà c'est là quand il
disait que vous étiez gênant aller votre
loisir préféré
oui le badminton oui c'est ça non c'est
le dessin mais le badminton ou non c'est
le dessin vous êtes toujours sur france
3 m ça se passe très bien
le temps que vous passez à vous
maquiller le matin oui on a sept ans
merci autres c'est pour votre surnom
quand vous étiez petit
oui c'est quoi menaces mais non cp
crainte de poule
crotte de poules merci attention la
tenue dans laquelle vous dormez ce qui
la connaît oui ni non non c'est terminé
merci c'est terminé vous avez combien de
points il a bel et gilles vous avez zéro
point merci pour votre accueil en
maintenant la déco
alors